golf three zero zero good morning
another 12 hour shift
they're picking up the victims of the
virus and the victims of lockdown
shirley had covered in january now her
daughter has had to call for help again
she's got pains in her chest um
but we'll see what we'll see what they
say hopefully it should be all right
and it's uh kobe is still with us he
wants to do one now
does it be edited and to know that you
can't go anywhere
it's just you know and you're just there
on your own and
it's you can see why people do go you
know
go off the red because it's just there's
nothing you can do is you can't go
nowhere you can't
can't do anything my name's kiera
mcclelland i'm a paramedic in wrexham
hamlet station
i'm vicky moran i'm a an emergency
medical technician for
welsh chamberlain service and i'm based
in maxin station i've not really known
much different i'm only 18 months into
the
role and there's colleagues of 30 odd
years who are saying it's
the most challenging time they've ever
seen and they're struggling and
questioning their question their roles
i've never seen
so many poorly patients in a small
amount of time i think that
will take its toll on anybody never mind
paramedic it's harder for family because
family
um will be about me they will be about
me more than i will be about myself
and so i think that's what you find hard
is you know they'll ask you know have
you had covered jobs today
well yeah we get code for jobs nearly
every day
and so yeah they they do worry family do
worry
the house is currently declared as a
redstone due to
the red
even though the patient they're seeing
has previously tested negative for
covid19 there are other residents here
who are positive and so everything moves
up a level
these covid jobs are thankfully slowing
down
but this isn't she's been found
collapsed in the streets she is possibly
an overdose
really sadly it sounds like she's lost
her dad to cover quite recently which is
probably
really brought her to this state that
she's in now
[Music]
when we get to the milo hospital in
wrexham the patient refuses to go
in there's now something of a gentle
standoff between the security
at the hospital here and the paramedics
and the patient who just doesn't want to
go inside it's
a difficult delicate job that they have
after almost an hour she's guided in for
specialist
care her family member had passed away
last night with covered and just unable
to cope with the situation at the moment
really
and it's on every shift sometimes for
the full
12 hours some shifts we we can see
every patient will have some element of
mental health whether that was the
primary reason for the call
or not and that makes it really
challenging for us because we have
limited
ways of dealing with these things other
than a e they're equally limited they
see medical patients
on top of those mental health patients
so they have to weigh up
the priority if there's no main medical
concern
it's purely a wait for the mental health
teams here and there's not enough staff
unfortunately
in the queue at the miler hospital are
soldiers helping out on ambulances
they've been on deployment since
christmas we're not any laws or nothing
like that we're just here to help
that's it i was opening my eyes quite a
lot because obviously you didn't think
it was as bad as it was
but when you when you're on there and
your ambulances gone to these houses
seeing the people seeing what's done to
them
you think yeah that's quite bad if you
notice that your [ __ ]
is becoming really really short of
breath
this is where the vast majority of
people find help with the one one
one call team our straightforward
symptoms of what we perceived as
straightforward calls to us
previously like your sore throats even
those type of calls now are coming in
with
some level of mental health issues you
know patients are really anxious
um but really scared so again this is
the the benefit of this service is that
we can actually
help and advise those patients he did
state that he's normally fitting well
he's just concerned about how does that
is an impact on the nation there with
the mental health and everything is
going on and
you know services have adapted out there
but i think one of the biggest
challenges is
basically looking after the staff as
well as doing everything else making
sure that the staff are okay
the next job is claire who's collapsed
at home with very low blood pressure
it's linked to a pre-existing condition
a very stressful year to be honest
i work in the wedding industry um and
we've had such a tough year and
the stress that we've all been under
with transferring
thousands of weddings but obviously
there's a road map out of it now so
hopefully
the stress is going to go away
claire is still coping but many more
people of
all ages are not and so this service
needs to adapt we're certainly looking
to enhance what we can do here in wales
certainly in the ambulance service to
support mental health patients and i
expect to see
uh more specialist mental health
services within the adwords service in
the next 12 months
yeah roger thanks um we'll make our way
back to base
thank you when kieran and vicky finish
marl and andy are in full flow every
single item on board is cleaned
after a covet patient we don't get to
know
what equipment has been used on the
vehicle or what medications been used
so for all i know that it may have been
opened and something may be taken out of
this box during the treatment but i'm
not aware of that
so better safe than sorry you cleared
everything
if it's on this kit you can wipe
coronavirus
but its side effects run deep and need
just as much care
tom parmenter sky news north wales